we're going to send that dog in
[Music]
okay thank you
second floor
yeah it's right above the steps this one
right here anybody out back in case he
jumps out yeah
i'll i'll go out back
i'll go
and the thunder rolls
biggest
i don't know
donovan
there's only one
this is window her car
a bunch of baby stuff
there's
there's no window
do you have another radio battery
oh you suck
[Music]
i told you
i said donovan
no there's a tiny one
can you see anything through the window
can you say anything
i would go watch that one window just in
case
i said i would watch that one window
not until i know they're inside
hey
[Music]
apartment h come to the door
columbus place
police department come to the door
department h
[Music]
come to the door
[Music]
hey come to the door
department h
open the door
i can hear you inside come to the door
hurry up
i'd like to tell dorothy to turn her car
off because i can't hear
hey dorothy kill the engine on that
cruiser
kill the engine
turn the car off
apartment h come to the door
we're not leaving
apartment h come to the door
apartment h come to the door columbus
police
we're not leaving
we know you're inside
wait maybe wait till dorsey gets up here
just waiting to get that
apartment h come to the door columbus
please 104 to 9101
donovan lewis we know you're inside come
to the door
come to the door
we know you're inside we're not leaving
once he gets back up here because she
said she doesn't live here anymore
i know it's only 10 days old
careful because you've got those
huh
huh i thought i heard people talking
she's like
yeah it's us are you in the apartment
she's like no i'm gonna go down double
well somebody's in here the deadbolt's
locked i'm not walking away from this i
agree
donovan if you don't come to the door
i'm gonna kick it in
if i have to come in there and get you
you're going to get tased
come to the door and talk to me do it
now
come to the door hands up
not here
come to the door i'm gonna boot the door
around
open the door
he said
columbus police apartment h come to the
door
yep radius industry
32 32 95
okay
okay open the door
he said he's not done that open the door
no you got the best spot
you got to duck down ain't nothing going
through that concrete huh
just duck down if you have to
jack just don't
show me your hands hands up face away
from me face away from me
hands up
walk backwards to me who else is in here
huh oh shoot okay turn around
got another person sitting there uh on
the bed
okay don't move don't move
[Music]
well stop moving
stop moving
okay
[Music]
you're just being detained real quick
okay
who else is in here how many people want
to come up here
okay relax
stop pulling away from me
another guy on the couch to the left
looking for donovan where is he at
um
so it's right there but it's protection
[Music]
yeah we'll have him hold that
is there anybody else in the apartment
we're going to send the dog in here in a
second so if he doesn't come out
so there's someone else in the apartment
cool
you know who's in the apartment that
you're in
he's going to get bit by dogs
so if he's in there columbus police if
you're inside make yourself known do it
now i don't know who's in the apartment
that you're in
we're going to send a
in in a second
right here
i can't tell if it's just a closet to
them they're saying nobody out there
collecting
if you're inside you'll stand on the ass
in this dog
[Music]
come out now
[Music]
that dog's gonna bite you if you don't
come out
shot
[Music]
we're going to send that dog in i'm
sorry 911
oh here i'm gonna lock him up
here
here
[Music]
hey